so I came on the police department in
July 1983 that's when I was sworn in
people ask all the time if I always
wanted to be a cop if it's something
that I aspire to do as a kid and the
honest answer to that is no I didn't
always want to be a cop the truth is I
didn't know for the most part what I
wanted to do when I was young I grew up
in Brooklyn could not see Brooklyn
which is kind of a wild neighborhood at
the time when I was young a middle class
neighborhood
um I had some wild friends and we did a
bunch of wild things and you know uh
my neighborhood had a lot of mob guys in
it a lot of cops firemen uh guys in the
trades and you know when you go up in
that kind of environment you could go in
all kinds of you could you know Veer in
all different directions as you grow up
when I was young like I said my friends
we were pretty wild on the weekends like
when we were 16 17 18 years old we'd all
get together and we go to this city
the city meeting Manhattan Guys from
Brooklyn and Neil lebows call Manhattan
the city especially back in the 70s and
80s that's how we refer to it and when
you're 16 17 years old and you're bored
and you're looking
looking for excitement
most of the time you find trouble and
that's as as those a young kid with you
know Wild Friends tough friends would go
down to uh where the trouble was we'd
specifically look for trouble we'd go
down to 8th Avenue and 42nd Street and
Broadway and and there was nothing but
high crime prostitutes pimps
drug deals in every every
hallway and every uh doorway the peep
shows it was a it was a really a crazy
time uh many times we got shot out shot
at by The Pimps simply because we were
they knew we were up to no good looking
for trouble and you know just uh
we had no real right being in such a
perverted and such a dirty and gritty
neighborhood to be honest but
growing up in that environment or coming
to Manhattan and seeing that stuff and
then going back to Brooklyn you know you
pick up things and you learn things and
you see things as you get older or one
year older than most most people most
legitimate people don't realize they've
never seen and
um it's having that experience that
helps a guy be a good cop or a female be
a good cop and
like I said I grew up with guys and
there was a lot of mobsters in my
neighborhood and we had a lot of
dealings with
Wise Guys what Italian mob guys and two
in particular led me to stay out of that
life not go into it
um actually it turns me it veered me and
turned me away from that life and I'll
just go into them real quick I'll tell
you uh
um so one of the most I was doing I had
a friend of mine asked me to get
involved with this burglary for a guy
named Eddie Lino Eddie Lino was John
Gotti's at the time right hand man he
was a known guy in my neighborhood he
was a drug dealer he was a known to be a
killer and he was a really bad guy and
he had made some kind of friend he had
some kind of relationship with one of my
friends and he asked my friend to do
this burglary for him and it was a
shuttered bar and to take out these
machines and these Joker poker and these
cigarette machines and get it to him and
we did it and when the time got when it
was time to get paid from this guy Eddie
Lino
um he
wasn't looking to pay us he was almost
looking to stiff us and and you know he
was looking to keep the money for
himself and not pay us what he had said
what he had agreed to and when I made a
little bit of a commotion out of the
fact that I wanted to get paid
um he begrudgingly did pay me but the
truth of the matter was I thought he was
going to shoot me in the head after he
gave me the money and I saw the
treachery and the deceit that a guy like
him even though he was a high-ranking
guy in the
in the gambino crime family even though
he was got his right hand man he was
still ready to shoot a 17 year old in
the head for just a couple hundred bucks
so that actually turned me off to that
well was the beginning of getting turned
off through that lifestyle
two of the guys that I actually did that
job with
a couple years later one of them had was
the head was decapitated it was found on
a beach in Brooklyn Plum Beach and the
other one uh again a few years later he
got a job working at a
armored car service
and apparently he didn't like working
there and he figured he could rip it off
so he got some guys together they ripped
off the armored car
they got caught and he flipped on all
his friends so again the the treachery
uh
the self-president perseverance it just
it's ever you know it doesn't stop in
that life
so that's one thing that's one incident
that turned me off the elementary that
turned me off was again as a kid 17 year
old we were hanging out in Brooklyn and
uh we got my friends and I got involved
with a guy named Bruno facciolo who was
a well-known uh lucasi mops in fact he's
the character that in the movie
Goodfellas he's the character that takes
uh Joe Pesci to his death when they kill
him so that was this guy of course this
is way before the movie but um he was a
known guy in my neighborhood and we get
in the dispute with him and at the time
I actually left right before the assault
my friends actually end up beating this
guy Bruno up
and um
the bottom line is Bruno found out
everybody that was involved who beat him
up and he took revenge on everybody I
wasn't involved I had walked away at the
time and I was already home by the time
my friends beat him up but he found out
everybody that was involved with beating
him up and the only way he found that
out is by one of my friends giving up
all my other friends
so again I you know you get to see the
recurring theme of uh self-presidents
and uh writing on your friends and so
those two incidents among others were
two of the things that kept me from
going into that life
um I still didn't know what I wanted to
do in life
um but I at some point take the police
test and I become I guess sworn in like
I said July of 1980 today
I originally get sworn in with the New
York City Housing cops which is at the
time they were three three departments
there was a New York City Housing police
which policed mostly the projects they
were the transit cops that did the
Subways and the regular city cops that
Patrol uh the streets
my first assignment was in Coney Island
and I was only 21 years old straight out
of the Academy I was with my field
training officer through all the cops
and my field training officer was a
older guy a well respected cop and he
knew the streets and he was inactive
even though he was up there in age he
was still an active cop
my first arrest uh it was kind of a
funny story well
yeah it's a little unusual we're walking
up to a building on 23rd Street between
mermaid and Surf Avenue the name of the
projects was called Carrie garnet and it
was one of busiest and most dangerous
projects in in Brooklyn maybe in the
whole city and uh
as we walk up to this particular
building there's a bunch of guys hanging
out in front of a building
and they're drinking and they're talking
loud and they're just hanging around in
their early 20s
some could have even been as young as 18
19. but they were about four or five of
them when they see me my fto Sal and the
two other cops approached the front of
the building
they all disperse except for one in
particular guy
as we walk up to the building my fto
turns to me and he says mike lock this
guy up
and I followed suit I did with my fto my
field training officer the experienced
cop I did what he told me I put the guy
against the wall I took my handcuffs out
the guy didn't give me a problem put his
hands behind his back he knew the
routine he'd been through it put his
hands behind his back I locked him up
now to be honest I I felt a little bit
um
actually like to stick to my stomach I
didn't know what this guy did I didn't
see him do anything overtly criminal and
it was a little bit upsetting to me I
put the guy in the cop car me and my uh
training officer go back to the command
back to the precinct and I'd grab him on
the side and I ask him Sal what did what
did this guy do that I locked him up I
wasn't confrontational I just had to
know what I what this guy did that would
leave me or Lead South to make me lock
this guy out
and what Sal said you know stuck with me
and again this is an older guy who'd
been through the mill he's a good cop he
said Mike these guys they've seen me
meaning him Sal go to the front of that
building and move them a half a dozen
times when they see me or any cop they
know they have to move they're not
allowed to be in front of the building
at ought to be drinking they're out not
allowed to be smoking pot they gotta
move
everyone dispersed except this one guy
what he was doing was he was testing me
meaning Sal he was testing the other
rookies and he's testing any other cop
that wants him to move he knows he's not
supposed to be there
he's got to go to jail he's got to get
us some it's basically it was a
disorderly conduct summons
um we bring him to the Station House and
that's what we were going to write them
up well when we brought him back to the
Station House we called the Warrant
Squad it was protocol to do that and he
had a bunch of warrants wanted he was a
wanted guy wanted about four or five
warrants for robbery for heavy assault
for a weapon I mean he was a bad dude
and Sal was right he knew he wasn't
supposed to be in front of that building
he was really testing the cops and
he basically uh Not only was testing us
he was trying to show that he was a
tough guy and what channel also said was
these guys in front of the building
they're actually keeping the people in
this project the good people hostage the
older people are afraid of them they
didn't want to go outside the young
women with their babies and with their
families were afraid of these guys were
going to harass them and they keep these
people in the project in this particular
building they basically keeping them
hostage and
he was right and that was my first
arrest was locking this guy up
again in the beginning I wasn't happy
with it but once the waters popped I
realized I was right this guy's a bad
dude he he deserves to go back to jail
and which which he did he went back to
jail
um after a couple of months in Coney
Island I kind of got bored and I wanted
to go to where there was a lot a lot
more action
and I ended up transferring to Alphabet
City Lower Manhattan Lower East Side and
the reason I wanted to go there was when
I was in the when I was actually going
to the police academy
every once in a while my friend's father
would drive me and him who was in my
class to the academy
and
very often he would drive take the
streets to the academy which was on 20th
Street and Third Avenue and he would get
off on Houston Street and he would take
which is the low east side and he'd take
the side streets and when we passed
these projects on the Lower East Side
you would see lines of people lined up
as if they were
at a at a cheese line or at a food store
and there's 20 people 25 people in a
line and then you see people nodding out
uh
you know like how are we nodding out on
the side
um people laid out on the street it was
really a uh it was it was horrendous and
it was disturbing and I remember asking
my friend's father who was a a SWAT team
cop uh
will respected cop again another guy
that knew the streets and I asked them
what's going on with these lines and
these people and he told me they're
online buying heroin and I even though
as a kid I went to Manhattan and 42nd
street and I saw drug deals and I saw
you know things that were uh
disturbing this was particularly bad
seeing people line up like this and I
asked him how come
why is this happening why is there
nobody taking taking action against
these people these drug dealers these
people cop and dope and basically he he
being on a job as long as he had been he
said the city knows about this
particular area which was called
Alphabet City he said the city knows
about this but it's contained and the
drugs are here and
it's not I mean there's drugs all over
the city so but this is basically where
drug addicts come to get high and it's a
contained situation and the city lets it
go on well
um
that's stuck in my head and after I
worked in Coney Island for a short time
just a few months I put into transfer to
Alphabet City and that's what I did I
transferred to Lower East Side uh the
projects Alphabet City which are wall
houses Reece houses but Rook houses uh
pit pit houses and some others and I
hook up
partnering with a guy named Jeff who
grew up in Brooklyn like me was just a
year or so older than me and we not only
became friends we we had we thought a
lot of life and
one of the Early times when we were
working together
everything let me just backtrack every
all the crimes on the Lower East Side in
Alphabet City
a very high percentage of
go back to heroin and the heroin trade
uh whether it's a robbery they're
sticking people up for money to buy dope
or it's an assault they get in a fight
over drugs or heroin most of the crimes
revolved around heroin the heroin trade
so early on me and my partner were
working we were driving in the car and
just to give you an example how brutal
brutal things could be down there uh
these two guys are walking uh down every
down 5th Street or Sixth Street and
Avenue D and a guy comes up behind him
with a bat and hits the one guy so hard
on the in the back of the head that the
victim's eye pops out of his head
and
um of course it was a gruesome scene the
Bibles on the floor the guy is down the
guy with the bat then turns and hits the
second guy and my partner and I grab
them and of course arrested him call for
emergency EMS and it all boiled down to
drugs this guy these guys got high with
this guy's girlfriend uh the night
before and they were screwing around
with this guy's girlfriend uh of all
because they all got high with the dope
from Avenue day and that's just the way
it was done there were shootings and
homicides all because of the well when I
got down there I originally went down
there to
make arrests and and I found it exciting
and I enjoyed the the chase so to speak
but little by little I started to
realize that a lot of the people in the
projects were good people and when you
start watching little kids
uh play with hypodermic needles and try
to stab each other or
coming down in the morning going to
school and they have to step over a guy
in their Lobby who shot up in the lobby
and defecated on himself and still has a
needle in her mom and
um
it was you know you start to realize
that these people really needed
somebody to try to help that that area
and that neighborhood and
my partner and I took it amongst
ourselves or upon ourselves to really
get involved and we did and
we actually did things that we weren't
supposed to do
um
you know a lot of these laws are written
and they kind of uh restrain the cops in
a lot of ways uh but we were working
down there first in uniform and we made
so many arrests that they put us in a
special unit and the unit was called
operation eight and that unit was a
plain clothes unit
that
specialized in the eight worst projects
in Alphabet City and it was mostly a
drug unit and a gun unit and that's what
we were focused on so my partner and I
two other cops and the sergeant we had a
vehicle that was uh
that was sponsored so to speak from the
federal government radio or some
training and
like I said the name of the unit was
Operation eight now
we have the know-how to lock up a lot of
these guys but it was hard for us to get
to the top Echelon we lock up the street
dealer we'd lock up the buyers
but it wasn't easy to get to the main
guys
but eventually what we did was we
started to break
protocol I guess you could say or Patrol
guides guidelines and we needed to know
who was behind the scenes and what we do
is we let people open up or sell drugs
on a particular day if they give us
information on who was supplying on who
was coming in with drugs and it worked
guys like I learned earlier as a kid
guys ran on their friends they ran on
anybody just to get ahead for
self-perseverance and that's what they
did they would we'd either pay them out
of our own pocket
with cash or we pay them with if we find
drugs on somebody we give it to these
guys and that would be their payment for
telling us what was going on and to
allow us to make them bigger arrests
was it right you know my vision at the
time especially in my estimation it was
that the ends Justified the means I
always feel that what we did
uh led to the bigger fish and always
helped
get the bigger guy and that's what we
were looking to do get get the main guys
we had informants uh
most of the time we like I said we took
care of them
but again it's always a risk and we've
we lost informants some one or two of
our informants had gotten killed either
talking to us or maybe they were talking
to other cops but again
the main guys the top guys were vicious
vicious guys and
in fact at some point they were doing
such a number on them and
putting such a hurt on their business
that they put a 50 000 contract on my
partner and the way we found out was
there was a uh a robbery pounding of
banks a bank robbery pattern Uptown and
the FBI had an informant and when he was
telling them about the bank robbery or
information regarding the bank robbery
he mentioned that there was a contract
on my partner and I down in Alphabet
City so this contract was confirmed they
temporarily transferred my partner and I
to Harlem
just to stay out of out of the view of
these guys
um but that really wasn't going to help
because we weren't even there one day
and we saw some of the Lower East Side
dealers Up In Harlem and they knew where
we were so
they were all over they were making so
much money they were driving brand new
mercedes-benzes Jaguars a Maserati and
that's before you could lease a car so
these guys were paying cash for these
cars and they were young kids I was a
young guy I was in my like I said early
20s 22 23 24 and they were just as young
as I were and they were making all this
crazy money
um at some point the DEA who we had
helped every once in a while they'd be
looking for a particular drug guy and
they'd ask yourself we know him and of
course if they were from Alphabet City
we knew everybody we'd pick them up for
the DEA
um at some point one of the groups in
the DEA group 34.
got involved with a case and they made
an arrest but the U.S attorney declined
prosecution on a couple of these drug
dealers they came to they found out that
my partner and I knew everybody that
came to us we knew right away who these
guys were they asked our chief if we
could go be assigned to the
DEA and we what we want we were assigned
specifically to the drug enforcement New
York group 34.
and
after
an eight-month investigation we were
able to arrest
40 of the Alphabet City drug dealers we
took down all the main people
um and basically we changed Alphabet
City from what it was to a nice
neighborhood in fact they even changed
real estate even changed it from
Alphabet City or from the Lower East
Side they started calling it these
villains uh
people came in they bought real estate
the whole neighborhood's completely
changed even to this day I mean there's
still some drugs there but nothing like
it was you don't see kids kicking
hypodermic needles in the street none of
that so
um I was really proud of myself my
partner the DEA guys operation eight we
did what we uh intended to do of course
like I said my partner and I risked our
jobs doing some of the things we weren't
supposed to do
however I felt that it was a
it paid off in the end
eventually a couple years later
I get assigned to
I leave the DEA and I get assigned to
the New York City's missing persons
division
now
that squad or that that um unit
isn't an active unit it's not an
enforcement unit people think when you
especially there's some TV shows with
missing persons on it's not like an
exciting unit and that's what I did I
liked going out I like locking people up
and this was completely
out of my character out of my nature to
deal with this it's mostly a clerical
unit
there's probably about 13 000 to 15 000
people that are reported missing in New
York City every year
for the most part those people come back
they're not really missing they're just
people that wander off and then they
come back or their runaways uh in fact
most of them are runaways and then they
get found or they come back
but occasionally there are legitimate
missing people who leave and no one
knows what happens to them but again
those cases are far and few in between
in any event while I was there I was
trying to pick up some old cases and see
if I could get something exciting going
work some cases that would
you know uh
keep me motivated and I found one or two
there was a case on the Lower East Side
a guy named Vernon Jones who's with uh
three of his friends and it was New
Year's Eve and he was in his house and
in his apartment and he got sick and
threw up and his friends went across the
street to buy some uh napkins to clean
up and in the process between going
across the street and coming back to the
apartment which took
tops two minutes he disappeared and he
was never to be seen again and I tried
to reactivate that case and I did
reactivate it but I came up negative
with with anything anything substantial
no nothing came up in the process of
fooling around with that case or
investigating that case
I get a call from an inmate in Attica
the guy's name was well he introduced
himself over the phone is Tiny that was
his nickname uh his real name was John
lentini now John lentini was a 350 pound
biker and he had been arrested actually
he was in jail in Attica for sodomizing
his two two little children and one was
an infant and uh
he was a demented pedophile obviously
and they arrested his wife too at the
time
but his wife ended up flipping on him
and saying she was forced into
sodomizing the children with him and he
goes to jail
well this happened in the he got
arrested in the early 80s by the time he
calls me it's the mid 90s that's when I
was in this missing person Squad and he
calls me and he says he has information
on a missing kid
uh and he butches the name but he means
the kid's name he means is Eton Pates
and it Tom Pates is a Infamous case here
in New York City where this young boy
disappeared in the late 70s he was going
to school on his own for the first time
his mother was looking out the window
she turned around for according to all
reports and her statement for less than
a minute when she looked back the kid
was gone Eton Pace was gone and that
happened down in uh the Soho area of
Manhattan
so this guy tiny this biker vice
president of his motorcycle gang
he says he has information on that
particular missing person kid now again
that was a well-known case so I made an
arrangements and I went up to see Tiny
and Attica when I got there with the
detective to interview him the
correction officer was a little
ambivalist about letting me go in there
and talk this guy along because he had a
violent pass but again it didn't matter
I had to go see him we went in we sat
down with this guy tiny so tiny tells us
this story and it's kind of an intricate
Story how about how he and his bike
again
used to do security for these rich
Elites in Westchester and Yonkers and
security meaning that he would secure
their homes their houses while they were
having Satanic rituals and sex parties
and Drug parties in these mansions and
he what he would do is he would get his
bike again for the Rat Pack and they
fell on the one of these major gangs I
don't know if it was the I don't
remember it was the Hell's Angels or the
Mongols or whoever they were associated
with but
they would wear their collars and they'd
go up to Westchester and Yonkers and
they secure the perimeter of these
mansions and in the Mansions was
supposed to be these
Satanic ritual parties and again
according to him
they were using drugs and having crazy
sex orgies and all that stuff and at
some point he
become so known to these rich Elites
that they invite him into the mansions
and basically he started to have having
to run run of the of the places and he's
going and out at his own Leisure while
his the rest of his security the rest of
his biker guys would hang outside and
again they were making sure nobody came
in they were making sure no cops came in
that was there that was their their job
so he tells me a in when I'm up there
now I can speak it to him
he tells me that at some point at one of
these parties
uh they have an author built in this
house and there's people on on this uh
stage so to speak and they call out this
little boy and
they call out the kid uh he again he
kind of butchers the name a little bit
but what he says is they call out Eton
page and they bring him on to this
stage and they give them some kind of
satanic blessing they do something with
with a rope they measure him or
something to that effect with this rope
then at some point they lay him on this
uh
altar that they built and he says at
that point he takes himself away from
the scene and he doesn't see what
actually happens but he later learns
according to him
that they
sacrifice the little kid
to Satan and they kill him on the on the
on this author
now
again I don't know how true this is this
is coming from Tiny
um he had a you know first-hand
experience according to him but he said
he left at this at the time but
everything else he said he witnessed he
personally witnessed him and and another
him and the president of the bike game
he was the vice president and at the
president of the bike gang has since uh
passed away
so I needed to verify first of all
um tiny was like I said he was a
pedophile he was uh I'm sure he was a uh
a liar he was looking to get out of jail
he was up for parole he was looking to
get parole this was this was how he
wanted to get paroled by helping us
again he had a history you know he
wasn't a good guy he was a criminal
but what he said and the way he said it
and somebody thinks that he told us
wasn't so outstanding or so unbelievable
that we couldn't follow up on it and we
did and we asked him to verify
certain names and a lot of the people he
gave us were people that were dead and
we couldn't verify because I needed
other witnesses to this particular
incident
what he told us was this particular cult
was the same cult that David Berkowitz
was involved with
now
David Berkowitz
for those people that don't know was a
serial killer here in New York City and
he killed like six people and and shot
like seven or eight others and he was a
serial killer from 1976 the summer of 76
until the summer of 77 when he got
arrested and he was killed uh kill and
shoot
very often that people in love his Lanes
guys and girls making out and love his
Lane he also shot some
some girls that were alone
um but he it was a 1976 when he was out
there he
put all of New York in the state of
panic girls with dark hair were
bleaching their hair blonde because
supposedly he only shot women with dark
hair
um they were with long hair they would
put their hair up in a bun and it was a
very well-known case it was um
as high profile let's say as a Zodiac
Killer but the New York version of the
Zodiac Killer Son of Sam the Son of Sam
was yeah his name was David Berkowitz
and he would leave notes for the police
to find and then he became corresponding
with uh the writer at The Daily News uh
Jimmy Breslin
and he would taunt the police anyway
this cult that tiny was involved with
is supposed to be the cult that
Berkowitz because bokowitz originally
when he gets caught he says his name is
dog told him to do these killings
and he basically was trying to
plea that he was mentally incompetent
years later he said he was there was no
dog involved he said he he broke which
was involved with this occult and the
cold met up in Westchester and Yonkers
and that's later what burkewood said
well that's the cult that this guy tiny
said was involved with this homicide
this kid homicide and Tiny gave us a lot
of stuff that was
we were able to verify
uh he gave us another killing
that we were able to verify and at some
point he gives us another Son of Sam
like killing two people in the love is
Lane in Cypress Hills in Brooklyn
it was never viewed by the police as a
Son of Sam type killing because the
victims were black
but tiny actually gave us the shooter uh
we went and interviewed him and we
actually got a confession from him
now
again burkowitz said that he was part of
a cult he said that he wasn't the only
shooter other people did these these uh
serial serial uh
crimes and shootings and homicides
and now here's tiny giving us a story
that's kind of matching Berkowitz
anyway tiny gives us information that
we're able to verify and
looks like we're going to be able now we
want to go see Burke Woods at some point
we had a lot of information
and just to backtrack a little Eton
Page's body had never been found at this
point
years later very recently somebody
confessed to killing it on Pace but the
person that confessed to killing Eton
paints paints had a mental history of uh
being mentally incompetent so nobody
knows if he really did he went to trial
it was a hung Joy the first time and
then eventually they convicted him but
nobody really knows if that guy who had
nothing to do with this was the killer
of Eton page we were still investigating
Chinese allegations
that was seeming to come come become
true with all the investigations we've
been doing
well at some point we make arrangements
to go see David Berkowitz
and ask him uh not only about Eton about
his shootings and about this cult and
this whole this whole this whole scene
and
the NYPD supervisors wouldn't let us go
see burgers
we continued the investigation there
were other people for us to interview at
some point they finally tell us stop the
investigation we don't want
just cut it out don't don't investigate
this anymore
without their knowledge I tried to go
see burkowitz again
I've since had correspondence with him
although he won't say anything about
these he doesn't talk to me about the
homicides uh
but the NYPD come cut us down again and
they wouldn't let me go see burkowitz
so
that's another case uh
we didn't get to the bottom of it's an
interesting case I would have liked to
have seen what happened and again like I
said even though tiny tiny was in jail
he was a known pedophile he was
obviously a bad guy he wanted to get out
of he wanted to get paroled and he was
giving us information
and a lot of the information
was verified some of the people he said
was involved we interviewed and again
like I said one guy admitted to these
shootings and they wouldn't NYPD
wouldn't let us follow up on that either
so that was a very strange case
people ask me all the time why don't you
think they would let you follow up and
go further with this uh I think because
my personal opinion is
Berkowitz was arrested the case appears
to be closed
a lot of people got promoted
um I don't think anybody really wants to
find out that there are more people out
there that were involved with this
homicide with these Berkowitz with the
Son of Sam uh homicides and I think
really that's why they kept us off that
case
so that was an interesting case
another case I worked in that same Squad
in the missing person Squad was the case
on this guy Andre Rand
was a
he had worked in a place called
Willowbrook
for those people that don't know
Willowbrook Willowbrook was the largest
mental state facility in the United
States at the time so they had people
with all kinds of mental problems there
uh Down syndrome
um any kind of mental incapacity people
were put there it was only Built for 2
000 people at the time this is going
back to like the 60s and they had over 6
000 people there
and the the staff
it was discovered was severely
mistreating this the the residents in
this place Geraldo Rivera did this big
uh expose on it back in like
1977 or 78 and he went in somehow with a
camera and he filmed these these
residents who were really victims and he
had them uh he filmed them in their own
depth defecation and and uh urine uh
with no clothes on it was it was really
a a terrible scene and this guy on Duran
worked there he initially worked there
as a some kind of maintenance guy and
then eventually he gets to become some
kind of physical therapist
without any training or
just somehow he becomes a physical
therapist for these people
in any event
Andre van was
a suspect in several homicides and
several missing children and
the missing kids that he allegedly
abducted were all
um
mentally incompassed incapacitated
he actually lived at some point on this
on the grounds of Willowbrook
it was a 300 acre facility and he
actually had like tents uh
built there for himself and some other
homeless people
uh and again he was implicated on
several uh missing children but they can
never pin it on him
he finally gets arrested for the
kidnapping of one of these little girls
and he's in jail at the time this has
gone back again to the mid-1990s when I
pick up the case I apparently I
eventually run into somebody I know
uh I tell them where I'm working and she
actually asked me if I knew a girl if I
was involved at all with this Holly and
news child
and I had never even heard of it at the
time Holly Ann Hughes was a little
seven-year-old girl who back in 1981
goes missing
and she told me Holly and Hughes lived
in Staten Island
and um it was a big missing person case
and she this person I'm talking to
actually knew Holly Ann used his mother
and uh she said if I ever get a chance
if I could look into the case
so I did I grabbed the case folder or
case folders
uh it was again it was another widely
publicized case and
I've seen that Andre van was the number
one suspect along with a bunch of other
cases he was involved with
at the time he was in jail but he was
due to be released
soon
I went I interviewed some of the people
I had been interviewed in the past
nobody would fess up that they actually
saw Holly and use with this guy Andre
rant people were afraid of him even
though he was inside people were still
afraid of him when he would come out
um
a lot of people thought he was involved
with Satanic rituals involved with uh
the same cult that burkowitz was
involved with because when they did grab
him originally he had satanic uh
paraphernalia books and and paintings
and they thought he was involved with
that same kind of stuff in any event I
was able to find one of the witnesses
that said he saw Andre Rand with the
girl but never saw them actually
together
uh well I grabbed this guy brought him
into a command and he was actually
afraid to be known as a rat and he
didn't want a rat on anybody even Joe
even though Andre Rand was this really
bad guy uh pedophile
a child abductor he didn't want to be
known as somebody that gave anybody up
but eventually he did and once this guy
gave up Andre Rand as being in the same
car as Holly and Hughes
uh we were able to rearrest well we had
some more investigation to do but that
was the nail that put Andre Rand and
that was the nail that closed the
scoffing basically and we were able to
charge him with the Abduction of Holly
and years we couldn't charge him with
the murder because they never found her
body
but we were able to charge him with the
murder of hollyanners
so that was another case that um we did
in that in that missing person Squad
going back to when I was in the DEA guys
asked me all the time what did I think
about uh
working as an undercover after we did
our big Alphabet City case I worked a
bunch of undercover cases and I know
guys always ask me how is it when you're
undercover what do you feel what do you
think like do you get scared yeah the
answer is you do get scared I've had
I'll tell you a quick uh
tell you two quick stories about just
working on the cover case I was doing
this case up in Washington Heights I had
this Dominican drug dealer in the car
with me a heroin guy I never met him
before I had just been introduced to him
the guy that introduced me to them got
out of the car
that guy I had drug done drug deals with
before but this particular guy I had
never met before
and we were up in Washington Heights
which at the back in the 90s uh early
90s late 80s was a really congested area
you couldn't park your car you couldn't
barely drive up there and
the guy makes me Circle the block a few
times and he tells me to pull over and
when I pull over there are guys shooting
dice literally right next to me I'm
pulled over in a fire hydrant spot and
the guys are shooting dice right next to
me
this guy
tells me
um we're gonna do this drug deal you
better not be a cop if I find out you're
a cop
I'm gonna kill you which was fine
because people said you know I expect
that I expect to hear that but what I
didn't expect was he told me he turned
my head when I turned my head the guy to
uzi machine gun pointed in my right in
my ear these guys playing dice they were
all part of this organization and he was
going to kill me uh
thankfully and thank God I was able to
convince this guy I wasn't a cop
we did the deal
and we went on we went our own ways and
we eventually locked up 17 17 or 18 drug
deals involved with this case
another time I was buying uh again
buying heroin and
when I gave the guy the money when he's
counting the money he's the money is
stained somehow with some kind of ink
uh
not that we like so when you make an
invest NYPD stamps the money DEA doesn't
put NYPD actually stamps the money
as a form of putting it out of service
and and to use it as a for evidence well
when this guy's counting the money
there's red ink all over the money
uh and I just took the money from the
DEA office and it wasn't stamped but
apparently Inc got on this money
and he took this money he took this as
thinking that it was buy money and that
we'd be able to identify the money with
this red ink on the money but it wasn't
and we get into an argument
uh the guy behind me was a known
Schuler who had already shot at a cop
and
basically I had a lie and argue with
this guy and fight my way out of it that
that was just a coincidence which it was
actually and I was able to get out of
that so
that's just a couple incidents that as a
that happens on the cover cop
um
and
being a cop is stressful isn't it
being a cop is uh could be stressful
yeah absolutely
yeah it's uh it's not easy you know you
go home you think about some of the
things you've seen uh you know going
back to Alphabet City people don't
realize that like I said earlier all the
all the a good percentage of the crime
relates back to the heroin I remember
going to an apartment once the the
there's a little bit the mother was
holding a baby
the baby had been dead probably several
hours at the time
anti-glassing envelopes of heroin in the
apartment
I tried to give the Kim out the mouth
but says I didn't try I gave it came out
the mouth but of course I didn't
resuscitate him the kid had been dead
already for some time uh
and again in the apartment the woman was
obviously a drug user who knows
what kind of what the situation was when
she fed this kid last how how she took
care of this kid
all this stuff is interrelated with the
heavy drug trafficking that was got down
in Alphabet City and you do actually you
know people wonder if you bring that
stuff home of course you bring that
stuff home you never forget that
do you like more peaceful now that
you've retired
now I'm retire life's more peaceful yeah
absolutely
yeah what have you learned about humans
after all your years being being a cop
on the streets
you know the truth of the matter is
humans in general I believe are good
people are good good in nature
but like anything else uh
people people want to better themselves
and sometimes it means selling drugs
sometimes it means pushing the person
next to you under the bus and uh you
know people about a lot of people out
for themselves not everybody but a good
portion of people are out for themselves
and they'll do whatever it takes to get
ahead
all right Mike thank you so much for
sharing your story thanks thank you for
having me we see the best of luck with
whatever you do from here on out thank
you man